‏s
[Silence]
السلام عليكم رحمه ورحمه الله
وبركاته
وبك الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه حي على
[Silence]
الصلاه حي على الفلا
حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله ثم الحمد
لله نحمده ونشكره ونستغفره ونستعين به
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا
من يهدي الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء قدير واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين وعلى من تبعهم
باحسان الى يوم الدين اما
بعد قال الله تعالى في كتابه المبين بسم
الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تمتن الا
وانتم مسلمون
صد الله
العظ mer bl
تالى as bl day
[Silence]
‏i'd to start by congratulating all
the students and parents of students who
finished another year of school in the
great state of arizona this is that affs
the and
da habits of many people not just
students
people to
‏are most importantly
weing most important alling foring us
day where we are
scho
bls nothing is
possible and so as i was thinking about
‏students school things i was
think
students and if they don't and they
might even have these questions
themselves first their classmates their
friends might ask them why
should people ask
mus res
‏are
الحدان anw and indicators we can
dees
reas we can inf just froms nature just
froms the world around us
‏gra
as le times more for all the
boun provided us pretty universal idea
that if someone gives you a gift what
are you supposed
to you're supposed to say thank
you how
you prim we many ways we
‏soare i don't want to take too much
time summer vacation after all for many
of
you few verses from the holy quran and
many more that indicate that give
reasons for why we should be grateful
and therefore why we should worship
allah
تىك المك the end الله
تعالالى بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم افمن يمشي مك على وجه
احدا يمشي سويا على الصراط
مستقيم صدق الله العظيم الله تعالى
‏more rightly guided
hepr on a
straight so if there a
straight الفاتحه احدنا صراط
المستقيم really two options you're on
the
path or you're not on
the you're on the
pa not on the help us st on the pa
‏right so
[Silence]
they قذ
ص والافئده قليلا ما
تشكرون سبحان الله الله
تعالى تالى
تالى hows
‏not too late day is young these are
things take for grant unless
laken over
time these are incredible gifts allah us
ears our eyes and our hearts and instead
of allah saying explicit thank me what
does
say says little thanks do you give what
does that me little
thanks
impc we
الله
تالى الله
تالى قل هو الذي راكم في الارض ويه
تحشرون الله
تالى anding us all back
‏res
he human beings are spre across the mus
spr acr are there muslims
country
people and in future we
allat isam
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادق
tru
res صلى الله عليه وسلم قل ان العلم عن
وانما انا نذير مبين صدق الله العظم الله
تعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله
تعالى علس
[Silence]
الله
تعالى فل را زلفه سيئه وجوه الذين كفوا
وقيل هذا الذي كنتم به تدعون صدق الله
العظيم سهى
‏when they see it meaning the punishment
when it comes judgment day and the
consequences those the faces of those
who disbelieve will be a they'll be very
distra they will be freaking out as we
might say in more modern english right
when they see what has been pred and
will be said to them this is what you
used to claim mean is you told the
propet صل الله عليه وسم bring this forth
if truthful very flipp right subhan how
could one talk that way
صل الله علسلم
so
butful
for eyes
hearts
many today the heart isn't just what's
beating and circulating the blood which
is of course very important it's also
where the soul is where the mind is so
also
‏worship and i encourage week have a
chance the 30th
holy
raning translation interpretation us a
very powerful incredible ins
[Silence]
الله
تالى الله الرحمن
اليم ومن اياته خلقكم تراب ثم اذام
ترون صظ الله
تالى created you
from natural matal made natural matal
and
[Silence]
الله تعالى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ومن
اياته ان خلق لكم من انفسكم ازواجا
لتسكنوا اليها وجعل بينكم موده
ورحمه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يتفكرون
صق العظ الله
تال our own type mean
our right partners spes
infor and love and mercy between
[Silence]
ومن اياته خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف
السنتكم
والوانكم ان في ذلك لاي
للعالمين صدق الله العظيم الله تعالى
‏and
and the
diversity among humans in
languages and in
colors do all humans look the same no do
we all have the same skin col
we says is amongs of تعالى we don't all
look the we don't all speak english or
one language
[Silence]
ومن اياته منامكم بالليل والنهار
وابغاكم من
فضله ان في
ذكي لقوم
يسمعون
صدق my fait is sleep sleep is aming gift
right maybe some of you if you have
school today you slept in little later
and you really for the gift sleep the
might come parents take you
schooling the year sleeping the day and
is sign
[Silence]
‏these are all
sign
like
take اياته يريكم البرق خوفا وطمعا وينل
من السماء
ايحي به الارض بعدض موتها ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يق صدق العظ الله تعالالى
[Silence]
‏des those flashes weeks rain
andain help may cut d make it eas for us
in light is among
as act incredible act sending down from
sking
raining dr
‏down ample to sustain life here in the
future so these are just a few from room
if you're coming late this is 30 in the
holy quran i encourage
everyone your homework school is over to
look at it to review it to reflect upon
it there so many insights and it's so
helpful in giving reasons to people if
they ask you whether at work or at
school why should i worship allah why
should i believe what's in it for me
what i getting out of it already
providing us with so so much
[Silence]
تعالى اقولوا قول هذا واستغفر الله لي
ولكم عباد الله استغفر ان الله غفور
الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله ثم الحمد لله اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
بعدد
[Silence]
have ‏for many of us it's summer
especially the young folks among us and
just because it's summer doesn't mean
you can't learn anything or study or or
think about things take a little break
you're probably a little tired but when
you're ready to start learning again i
strongly encourage you to try to
memorize a s perhaps
summer maybe read a maybe read one the
longer you haven read in a while maybe
read some had if you have never heard
of0 might be a good summer to find out
what it is there c all over the ‏over
commun as well asline and so deve to
increasing our relig knowledge can be
difficult during the school year we have
math we have social studies we have ela
we have all sorts of classes we have to
take and it's usually not arabic or
islamic studies but so summer is a very
valuable time to benefit and to take
advantage of the fact the schools go all
months of the year ‏i was امام الخاري
رحمه
الله
خطتا to say something about which is the
word for knowledge usually religious
knowledge but can be translated science
as well and i
was حثم الخاري الله
he حث سبحان الله
[Silence]
حثه المجادله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يرفع
الله الذين امنوا منكم والذين العلم
درجات بما تون خبير
‏caned eng among who believe
gred
byes
تىى وقال ول
[Silence]
حث صلى الله عليه وسلم لا حسد الا في
اثنتين حس الا فيت
رجل اتاه الله مالا فصلت على حلته في
الحال ورجل اتاه الله الحكمه فهو يقضي بها
ويعلمها صدق رسول الكريم صلى الله عليه
وسل
الله case other
حرم not
given
acc teach
‏if are
se ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار ربنا اغفر لنا
ولاخواننا الذين سبقونا باليمان ولا تجعل
في قلوبنا غل الذين امنوا ربنا انك ؤف ال
رحيم ربنا لا تؤخذنا ان نسينا واخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اسرا كما حملته على
الذين من قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ما لا
طاقه لنا به واعف عنا واغفر لنا
وارحمنا انت مولانا فانصرنا على قوم
الكافرين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
والسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين امين عباد الله ان الله يامر
بالعدل والحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينها عن
الفحشاء والمنكر والبخ يعذ لعلكم
تذكرون اذكروا الله واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حيا على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا صراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
افمن يمشي مكبا على
وجهه
اهدى ام من يمشي سويا على الصراط
مستقيم قل هو الذي انشاكم وجعل لكم السمع
والابصار والافئده قلي ما
تشكرون قل هو الذي ذراكم
في الارض واليه
تحشرون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل انما العلم عند
الله وانما انا نذير
مبين فلما راه زلفه سييت وجوه الذين كفروا
وقيل هذا الذي كنم به
تدعون الله
اك سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا صراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم
ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم
اليدين
الله
اكبر سمع سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم
[Silence]
ورحمه السلام ورحمه الله وبكاته ان شاء
الله ‏thank
youl
hees tri for be answer for growing up
you know that was one things i school
not america i didn't gr up all the
so back home you
will
weak
‏brother and sch
trans
announcements beil sch trans ann
days الله
تالال
sch us mct
‏sch
transes
and anybody
[Silence]
and
free sister
[Silence]
‏you here
about
130e doesn't what
gr come
[Silence]
الله
ع
[Silence]
‏sk
ا
[Silence]
ان